- This is, this is
Saturday before you go out.
- This is the morning after,
the walk of shame hair.
(upbeat jazz music)
- So today we're going to
try and guess which of these
Amazon products are rated
higher then its counterpart.
- I use Amazon so much,
like, I probably use it
every single week.
- I 100% go off of ratings.
How many people rate it and the stars.
- You can't just trust the brand.
The seller to be like
this product is great,
you should use it.
- Buying online you have really no idea
what you are getting
until its at your door.
(upbeat pop music)
- We're going to start with selfie lights.
- This is already difficult cause
I don't know how to turn it on.
- Okay, so yours has a little cord.
- You have to plug it in to your computer?
- No, that's for charging.
- Oh.
- Lights it up, that's pretty cool.
- Oh it gets brighter.
- Okay. I feel like a Kardashian.
- I feel like a beauty blogger.
- You would clip it onto your phone, here?
- We can't tell because
there is too many lights.
(upbeat pop music)
All right, so I'm going to take
one without that much light.
- It does define the
jawline and all of that.
- Oh.
- Oh. That got really bright.
That's like the sun.
- Even just vlogging, like, that, this.
- 5 star, 1 star.
- I'm going to say this
one is the higher rated.
(bell dings)
- Yay.
- Good.
- Good job.
- I know a good selfie.
(light jazz music)
- Alright, Louis, smell it first.
- This looks painful.
Like that looks dangerous.
That seems like, yeah, Marty
does not like that one.
He's like no.
- Little mouse thing.
It is nice that you can just,
like pull it off though.
- It doesn't get any hair out.
Look, like no hair sticks to this.
- I can get more fur off of
him just going like this.
- Yeah.
- Do you see that?
- That looks like tack,
this looks like hardcore.
This is a tool, this is something
you find in the tool shed.
Wow that's no joke.
- Is it doing things?
- Yeah, that is no joke.
- I'm going to say this
is the highest rated one,
and that is the lower rated one.
- Okay.
- I would say this is
a lower rated product.
(bell dings)
- Duh.
- Yeah, that was kinda obvious.
- Oh my god, we are so close
to getting a Murphy #2.
(upbeat pop music)
- Oh, oh there's so much.
- This ones fuller.
- Yeah.
- Its definitely got a lot more hair.
- I have a little bit of hair.
That I can try and clip this into.
- So is this a mullet situation?
- I love this, I'm having
way too much fun with this.
- So yeah, I think this
is the higher rated one,
and that's the lower rated one.
I think we agree.
- I wanna say mine is the better one,
it just looks more natural,
it looks great on dogs.
- I bought a Party City
wig, and this feels like
Party City weave.
- Poor thing. This one just needs a brush.
- That ones snaps smoother.
- This is the 5 star one.
(bell dings)
- Yay.
- Ow.
(upbeat pop music)
- This looks like either a
dog toy or not a dog toy.
- Or if was made out of something else,
like a really interesting sex toy.
- How's that feel?
- I hate this.
- You hate it?
- I hate it.
- Oh god.
- It seems like this one
can go in more crevices.
- They feel the same to me I
have no idea what's better.
- This black one definitely felt bouncier,
like more comfortable.
This is just turning into
a transformation video
- It is.
- I don't know if I
can see the difference,
but this ones way sturdier.
- This is the more highly rated product.
- I think this is going to
be the higher reviewed one.
(bell dings)
- Yes!
- Good.
- I think we know which
one, is not the one.
- No?!
- What?
- And that's what Murphy
was trying to tell us,
she was trying to tell
us that this is the one.
(bell dings)
- Yay.
We have been alright so far.
- We're so good at this.
We buy way too many
things on the internet.
(upbeat pop music)
- This looks like either
a lipstick or a vibrator.
- This is beautiful, I
thought this was going to be
lipstick...
- Me too.
- but it's not.
- It is a vibrator.
- This is horrifying, also its beautiful.
- Just a little bit at the top.
- Where do you shave the.. Oh!
- Oh, personal shaver.
- I thought it was for the nose.
- I totally was about
to put this on my face,
and now I won't.
- Yeah, it's not doing much.
- Have you ever shaved your arm?
- No this is 25 years of arm hair.
- Does it hurt?
- No it doesn't hurt,
how do I have hair on the
inside of my elbow?
That's disgusting.
- That is functional right there.
- It did a pretty good job,
it has some little hairs.
- Okay, already I feel
like this one is faster.
I'm going to give this my highest rating.
And that..
- Because its faster?
- Yeah because its way faster.
- Cause I think people
on Amazon are smart,
I'm going to vote for this
one being the higher one.
- For sure that one.
- For sure, I think this one
has the lower rating.
- Lower rating.
(buzzer)
- What?!
- What, this is the higher rated?
- I would pick this one over that one.
- My like trust in the average user on
the internet is still intact.
- I think 100% they
were really fair.
- Oh yeah.
- I think for the most part,
we agreed with the ratings.
Thank god.
- I will keep relying
on the reviews for sure.
And I will keep using Amazon.
(upbeat jazz music)